hello everybody and welcome to part 16
let's play amnesia the Dark Descent we
just left off with me kicking the ass of
some whoop okay up yep yep time to pass
out as usual haha was it pass out or
clock I'm my watch must have died aha
Alexander doesn't have friends
what's this talking about oh yeah right
feeling as you should stud Gary
why oh really
well let's pay them a visit
I'm sure nothing's gonna go wrong
oh yeah that's great of course
good job Daniel yep yep yep yep nothing
new here
Daniel's crazy yeah whatever it's pretty
much expected now yeah okay
oh good nap okay Oh rose petals why no
idea give me give give
I said give up that way give yep
mine can't have water much dirt get me
fine
Oh cuz I go in the wrong way wow that
was useful I'm glad I did that
hello red goo nice shut up
see more red goop boring gamma way beam
alright I'll move sorry sorry beam oh no
oh oh where I was okay
going down the staircase and going down
the big staircase so exciting barrel got
my white barrel oh yeah knob yep I did
something
Yeah right Oh never love my lovers good
chunk oh that's good yeah crunch smack
crunch yeah yep yeah tip the box limit
in the box all right what the hell am i
doing I don't even know chair get out
here chair Cheers
I'll need you to fight the monsters
can't be ah-ha-ha-ha oh yeah oh yeah
couch tainer
oh oh yeah ah fine whatever
ah yeah okay smart smart smart smart
mark right yeah oh yeah
kou Chung yep
just to add a bit of green bit of
magical green where my bone go oh I took
my bone yep that's him right okay oh
yeah oh oh sorry
house rule good head of myself that's
what they all say
get ready crunch squish oh yeah once
yeah there we go that's what I was
looking for hey got layers tonic give me
my chair I'll bring it on [ __ ] I'm
scared of him
yeah chair as if that stopped me Oh No
kidding
got it Wow
yeah no kid that's normal cuz that makes
sense sure needs a heart I didn't say
anything what are you doing you crazy
old man I feed you tonic
drink up supersuit whatever what with
what i can't whack your head what do I
do
ah ha ha uh uh saw saw saw saw was a
good movie sequels not so much box saw
oh how convenient a bone sucks ok but uh
it won't budge again something non
budging door what's in here why we got
you yeah we're more blood I need more
blood do i what am I saying
probably ten gallons of blood before
these I'll shut up about Alexander off
with your head yeah okay okay
okay all right whatever perfectly normal
locked
[Music]
yeah shouldn't trust him why would I
he's a loser
he's got no head ah my face it's all
over my hair let's shut up shut up
[Music]
Yeah right back in this place I love
this place so much
who's there hold on oh yeah oh [ __ ]
okay yeah whatever
you're not that scary that part went
down it's gonna splat me oh yeah ah come
on that's right I'm the best I'm on now
yeah who did yeah yeah yeah
get back funky cat
yep hot tar so smart tents Martinus
points to me does this make sense tar
it's a perfect adhesive for a magical
extra dimensional orb
yep yeah it makes it
Oh
all right yeah go go go beams of light
go all right I [ __ ] you what'd I do
oh come on chub wound dan you're such a
pansy
oh that makes sense why would an
ultimately powerful orb do anything
useful oh god dude that monster I'm
gonna pause it here for a second
thanks for watching guys stick around
for part 17 bye bye